how many seasons do you think curb has
left do you think this is the final one
do you think you guys do a ton more you
know it's funny no one has ever asked me
that and i'm not being sarcastic
i can be skeptical i'm never sarcastic
and i want us
no no because people say uh you're gonna
do another like no one ever says
how many more can you do i think
we could maybe do one more
yeah maybe you know larry's in his 70s
he's don't get me wrong he's in good
shape genius yeah
yeah i do both the goldbergs and curb
i'm 50 [ __ ] nine it is exhausting
it rips me apart and the equivalent
happens to larry because he's in every
scene
working every day having to be there at
6 30 in the morning
um i don't know if physically he can do
more than let's say another season right
i think he could do another
i don't know that he has two in them
when you guys were doing that
yeah when you guys were doing the pilot
you know you often hear people say when
they read a pilot
they can envision that they go we've got
a winner here we've got something big
did you guys have any idea obviously if
larry david's involved but
did you guys know that this was gonna be
what it ended up being which i think
is is is truly the greatest comedy
of the last quarter century
well you're very kind to say that and i
will take that in and say
thank you i think i'm right i mean ben
am i right there a hundred percent yeah
a hundred times
i was just with michael imperioli last
week posting yeah
and i said in my opinion
the 90 minutes that was like three
seasons
of the sopranos going into curb
that 90 minutes for drama and comedy
yeah
i think is the best 90 minutes in the
history of television you're probably
right
you know i really do by the way i'm not
a
i don't have a big ego i don't think
that i or
i don't believe the hype but i have
great respect for curb your enthusiasm
and obviously great respect for the
sopranos and that
90 minutes was just
you know they use the term must watch tv
right to me
if you want to laugh and feel emotions
that's your 90 minutes all time well
both shows had
some of the the the truly great
practitioners of the art form
in it right and people like you and
larry and susie essman
one of the things that i was always
curious about uh
people have said a lot of curb is improv
how much of the show is improv
how much of it is scripted
is there a balance that's a real thing
that i'm
very curious i wanted to answer your
question earlier yes
we did we had no idea okay we were going
to become
this iconic show we what we did the key
thing that you've done in your career
what do i find interesting you have to
do what you
find interesting and if you do that
either you hit or you don't
boom that's it but that's the only way
to hit in a big way is to be yourself
so we did a show that we thought was
funny
we didn't have a clue if another human
being would like it
i did think early on that it would do
well in
england because it had a faulty towers
flavor right
um yeah um yeah
so there you go what about how much of
it is on the spot
on the fly all of it all of it
in the story larry might write in the
outline
the outlines are about seven pages long
a normal sitcom script
is about 30 some odd pages
so that's a lot of that's a big
difference and so
larry writes these scenes which we truly
improvise every once in a while there'll
be a line of like
uh jeff says this or jeff tells larry
this
which if he says jeff tells it's kind of
like i can do it any way i want well i
can do it any way i want anyhow
um so yeah now
cheryl hines susie essman you larry
um
richard lewis everybody on the show
is a killer like everybody on the show
is amazing
and what is the
working environment when you have comics
that are
that skilled and that good
when you guys are improvising uh is
there just a real
understanding of of what your characters
are does anybody try to hog a scene
or steal a scene did it take a while to
because i can only imagine me and my
friends and the ideas that everybody's
trying to have the last word and
be the funniest person well with me
automatically you've got the guy that
will hang back
if other people and it's only guest
actors
who sometimes will do a little much and
we have to sort of pull back
right but in terms of the main people
it's a feeling here's the feeling and
again no one's ever asked me this
it's a feeling of trust when you know
when you walk
on that set it's like i know everyone
who's here can do their job
it's their ultimate it's walking on to
an arena with pros with people that
are equivalently on it it's like it's
like the nba playoffs are now
it's going out nobody's injured and
everybody
you know what everyone does and everyone
knows their job
sometimes you have to step up in other
ways but it's that trust factor
and what does that trust factor bring
you uh
hopefully good work but but [ __ ] joy
we la we work very hard and long hours
but we laugh all day long well that's
the other question you guys
everybody laughs it gets along is there
a and i don't know i mean this is a
question somebody probably has asked you
before it's a hack question as i ask it
but it's all right i'm so happy to be
here with you no i'm happy that you you
did it
i'm this is i'm i'm a fan of so few
things
but this is something i'm a huge fan of
is there a movie
in there is there a curb movie is there
is there a long
form 90-minute two-hour
movie whether it's on hbo or it goes to
netflix like
is there a car in my opinion yes i i i
personally don't think so and i wouldn't
aim in that direction because i love
movies
and i think curb is unique to
what we do and it's a half hour
sometimes a little longer
not very often a little shorter it isn't
it's perfect for what it is
to me i'm a believer you know movies are
a different art form
they really are 100 and it's
storytelling
but it's a different art form you go
into all right
i'm not even going to use the same genre
um
you go into most of the crime i love the
true crime stuff on netflix i watch all
of it yeah
okay and the best ones
are where the story's already been told
the night stalker
um any of those where
we know who did it and that dude
is dead right that story
however if you do five episodes it's
compelling
now so many of those
five six ten episode art uh
true crime uh documentaries are
um many episodes
too long they're they're sort of milking
it
and we get to the end and we know as
little as we did when it started
and it is it's something that could have
been truly
i'll even give them credit i won't even
say a half hour it could have been an
hour long
and we would have gotten the same
because there was one recently
about the hotel downtown and the woman
that disappears yeah
i watched it i said the same thing it
could have been an hour it could have
been a podcast
yeah so what i think we
realize about curb is it's perfect as a
half hour
maybe on occasion a special hour
if it's right but in general you don't
want to be making movies out of this
it's the same thing you know there's
nuance to
everything that's great i think and then
you know for example you know what was
great about uh sopranos
was they hired real directors it wasn't
like the writers
are gonna start directing uh uh what was
the other
thing where they all right uh um
breaking
bad better better call saul um
vince gilligan directs some of the
episodes
but mind you he's a great director right
but there's
nuance between being a showrunner slash
writer and being a director yeah so it's
the same thing
whatever it is if you go with it you're
always going to serve
yourself and serve the people watching
who directs curb is it one person or do
you have rotation well now
now it's been jeff schafer i was one of
the producers direct
this year actually he directed every
episode last year we had half jeff
schaefer
have a bunch of great women directors uh
and then in the past we've had other you
know directors and stuff
uh but um yeah it's uh you know look
it's larry david's voice right and then
tv
it's just as long as but my job is to
get
when i'm doing a scene with larry david
i'm not trying to be funny
he wrecks the scenarios they're funny my
job is to help get larry david's story
on the screen
in the best way possible well what's so
great about what you do and what your
character does what i think ben
does here is that when you put something
you add
something you don't do it all the time
but it's always gold it's always perfect
it always moves the scene to where it
needs to go it's
pivotal it's not it's never excess
that's why i was curious about
how much of it is written how much of it
is because
try and run away with it nope right
every scene we listen to one another
where where um
richard lewis and bob einstein were a
little bit different they had
they would look over the scene and
richard would actually write notes to
himself
and we'd do a scene and we'd have to
steal the notes away from him
because we want him to be present right
but he would all his mind he wanted to
have
fun equips ahead of time right bob
einstein a lot of times
i would say what are you doing because
he wanted to just be
so damn funny which he was i mean one of
the
funniest people on that show
uh without question bob jb smoove
amazing and susie esman is
just i mean everything she does and says
is truly amazing